there are some Christmas traditions you
can almost set your clock by and the
Queen attending church at Sandringham is
one of them Her Majesty was joined by
senior members of the royal family for
the Christmas morning service at the
Church of st. Mary Magdalene security
around the estate was tightening but the
atmosphere was festive and fun well
every year now at Sandringham the
numbers here grow and grow some people
were queuing from before 6 a.m. this
morning Christmas morning to catch a
glimpse of the Royals there was
disappointment for those hoping to see
Prince George while Prince Harry even
got a cheeky marriage proposal who then
say anything I have to wait we have to
wait maybe thanks sure maybe next year
I've been coming for 36 years this year
just keep coming another year in another
year and you know a lot of people and a
lot of same faces coming again and I
even think the world recognized you
sometimes from one year to another
certainly for dog if not the people I
got to talk to Charles in her Christmas
message the Queen paid tribute to those
leading the fight against Ebola in West
Africa I have been deeply touched this
year by the selflessness of aid workers
and medical volunteers who have gone
abroad to help victims of conflict or of
diseases like Ebola often a great
personal risk and on the 100th
anniversary of the Christmas truce in
the World War 1 trenches Her Majesty
reflected on her visit in October to see
the poppies planted in the moat at the
Tower of London the ceramic poppies at
the Tower of London drew millions and
the only possible reaction to seeing
them and walking among them was silence
for every poppy a life
and a reminder of the grief of loved
ones left behind the Queen also
mentioned the independence referendum in
Scotland and how some people felt
relieved afterwards while others were
disappointed the overall theme of this
year's message one of reconciliation and
Brady Sky News at Sandringham